how long do you feel like you need to
give something a fair shot
90 days 90 days there we go i
that's a high five right there jeez
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today
on the show we have jordan syett who is
a trainer big in the fitness community
he is
funny as all get up on instagram he
makes fantastic videos he has alter egos
he wears
wigs i mean what else do you want to
know he's hilarious
so we laughed a lot but for sure we
talked a ton
about fitness we talked about the um
i feel like the title of the show should
be like don't be an [ __ ] because
that's kind of his theme is like
you know everything in in moderation in
general but like
it's common sense things like if you're
not in a caloric deficit
you're not going to lose weight stuff
that we know but we just kind of don't
want to hear it so
he puts it straight to us tons of
fantastic info if you're interested in
fitness and food at all you're going to
love this
uh jordan syoth thank you so much for
coming on the pretty intense podcast
i i'm actually fairly intimidated right
now because i wrote a workout program
called pretty intense okay it's like a
book and a program and everything
and um you are a real trainer
and i'm just like a glorified lover of
working out so
you are going to be my new guru when it
comes to
everything that i have questions on and
like i said i've worked out my whole
life and so if i have questions
i got to imagine somebody else out there
has these questions well i'll answer any
questions i'll
be straight forward i'm equally if not
more intimidated so we're both
intimidated right now fantastic this is
going to be a good conversation then
i'm sure we won't be at all nervous uh
so
but first like let let's like give a
little background i i
i you know i follow you on instagram you
are uh
hilarious um inspirational and
no [ __ ] and i love that like you
inspired me to actually track my
calories when you were like
you could try this this this this this
anyway all that matters is you're in a
caloric deficit and i'm like
yeah okay i'm sure i am and then i was
like you know what i don't have to get
an app and i'm gonna
actually like i can usually write it
down based on knowledge
like just like but let's not even do
that let's like either you could scan
barcodes in through things and you can
be super duper detail-oriented and so i
did that and i went what did you get
uh i did the my macros so
i i started doing it and i was like
oh [ __ ] i eat way too much fat
it's like i thought i was eating like
maybe 1200 calories a day
and i was like nah i probably was eating
2 200.
yeah yeah okay so anyway that's just
my like super excited you've helped me
transform
what i thought was something i had under
control um
but anyway so tell me your background
how did you get into like what made you
want to work out even in the first place
so i started wrestling when i was eight
because you're a trainer let's establish
that
i'm a trainer yes i'm a trainer and i
started wrestling when i was eight years
old
okay i was like i love sports athletics
no cauliflower
though thank god yeah
[Laughter]
so wrestled from 8 to 18 and when i got
to
high school i made varsity as a freshman
wow i cut a lot of weight so
i cut from 112 to 103. so i was cutting
a lot of weight
it was really small those numbers make
sense to me because that's the size i am
got it okay it's a lot it's a lot and
when you're that small it's a huge
percentage of your body
yes so because i made varsity
i was going against juniors and seniors
and so
technique-wise i was good speed-wise i
was getting dirt-wise i was good but
strength-wise i didn't have it
especially with those older kids so i
had to learn how to cut weight while
getting stronger at the same time
and that's the main goal of so many
people how do you get stronger while
losing weight and
so i started to dive into it right i
applied to
uh intern at the gym and the first year
that i applied to i got denied that i
didn't want a 14 year old kid walking
around here
and the next gym they accepted me which
was a huge blessing
and so from 14 all the way through high
school because you're not because
essentially you weren't allowed in
because of your age
because the first thing what they said
was they were
like our clientele won't want a kid
walking around like shadowing and
looking
so i was like i was i was actually
devastated yeah i was like
so go apply to another gym which was
like i was like okay oh
thanks mom so i did that and i got
accepted to the next gym which was it's
been amazing and they were very
science-based
and so i worked there all through high
school and then at the end of high
school i
actually took a year off i lived in
israel for a year and then
when i got back to america then i went
to school and
i started majoring in exercise science
okay but
my sister what i realized was that
basically everyone knows what to do they
know they should be eating healthier
they know they should be working right
so why aren't they doing it right so i
realized majoring in exercise science
learning about learning all this stuff
wasn't going to help as much as help
learning the psychology the right people
do the things they do so i switched to
behavioral health psychology
sort of to understand the science behind
why people make the decisions they make
because you can have the best program in
the world the best nutrition the best
workout the best whatever but if you're
not following it
what's the point so i wanted to figure
out how could i get people to be
consistent mm-hmm
something mm-hmm so that's what hey man
and then i was competing in powerlifting
and i went through college and i started
writing articles sort of to document my
journey and
uh then started coaching people online
and then became gary vaynerchuk's coach
down the road and
sort of went from there you talk about
the psychology of working out and
my book pretty intense the the the book
is broken down into three sections and
the first section
is mind body the first section is
talking about
how are you going to develop the right
psyche
to my hope always was to make sure that
the
program was not something you'd just do
for three months to lose weight because
as i told people
you will like you will lose weight if
you do the program you're going to then
what are you going to do after three
months if that's your only goal
what are you gonna do then so the point
was to like hopefully get it ingrained
into them
the reason why they're doing it being to
feel better to
you know looking better is great that
that can
be maintained then but to to feel better
and to
to eat to feel better too and what was
crazy is that people would start doing
and they'd start on the diet and then
they'd like
have a cheat day and i had a forum for
the trial group for the workout program
and i was hearing people say like oh i
ate pizza and i felt so bad
i wished i hadn't and you're like yes
because you should eat to feel good not
because you're like oh god i have to eat
this broccoli and think of it in a
negative way like i won't feel good
like i don't even desire bad food
because it just like doesn't make me
feel good so the book focuses on the
psyche
and you spent a ton of time from my
understanding
seven years straight training gary
and on the road everywhere that he went
so please tell me about gary please tell
me about that experience yeah so
actually coach gary for three years
three years straight
non-stop every day seven days a week and
let's establish who he is and what he
does
he's like the ultimate entrepreneur
right he's just like and he's
talk about intense he's the most intense
person you ever meet right
he's so passionate he loves what he does
he's the kindest most caring guy but he
works harder than anyone right now
right he's amazing okay um basically
he decided to get a personal trainer and
he worked with my buddy mike first and
then they did a two-year arrangement
where they would work out seven days a
week
mike then when mike's contract was up
there was like owning another coach and
i was like in israel at the time
and mike knew about me because of my
content online and he liked what i was
doing and i helped him a lot
okay so basically he recommended me to
gary okay from television
got hired within an hour basically
basically and then
so the whole a lot of people hear that
gary works out seven days a week they're
like
what the hell's the point of that like
that's too much that's bad oh good well
we're going to get to that that's called
the rest days topic i want to talk about
that because i'm not good at it
so basically for me the way that i spoke
together
you don't need to work out seven days a
week okay if someone needed to work out
seven days a week
then very few people would actually do
it at all because they would be like why
bother yeah what if i have to do seven
days a week yeah
for gary it's not that he needs it from
a physical perspective it's more like
when he makes working out such a daily
habit like brushing your teeth
or getting dressed or just feeding
yourself taking a shower when it becomes
the daily habit
then all of a sudden it's just part of
your schedule and you just do it no
matter what amen and when you think
about it something that you just do
rather than something okay well this is
only monday wednesday friday i think
it all it becomes much more easy to just
do it
you also give yourself more leeway like
a lot of people if they miss a workout
they think they screwed everything up
they missed a workout they made a week
of workouts it's like yeah i screwed
everything up
and so when you just have it planned
into your daily schedule
even if you miss one it's not a big deal
because you're going to go back tomorrow
no one workout or one meal where ever
will ever crush you that's exactly right
so so yeah basically wherever gary was i
would he was in hong kong i was in hong
kong if
he was in london wow what did you leave
behind in israel then where you had a
job there i'd imagine well so
my business was solely online so
i went to israel and i had some
in-person fights but i just love it
there mm-hmm
i'd love to go have you no but a friend
just went and the pictures looked
phenomenal it's incredible okay well
that's a whole nother topic
so i was living in israel and i was just
working online and then
gary's coach reached out to me and said
hey i think you know gary would like to
work with you
yeah i mean coach gary i mean obviously
i mean gary vee
is extremely inspirational he's
extremely direct
um he's a fast talker
um you better be listening uh like he's
but he's very inspirational and he's
you know he to me is like part of the
wave of the future
of the way you need to be thinking so um
you know you were already tuning in to
the mind
and what needed to happen so in my mind
you kind of attracted gary based on the
fact that you
understand the gravity of that and how
important it is
so what was he able to add to
your already seeking mind on this topic
you know it's really interesting there's
a lot gary has given me a lot
mainly from a psychological and
emotional perspective i think
i talk about this one a lot i think this
is one of the biggest things you've done
for me
okay everybody has insecurities
[Music]
and one thing that i think happens on
social media is
consciously or not we tend to hide our
insecurities
we tend to try and put out whether it's
through a filter and an image
or whatever you're writing about you
show your best self
which ironically it exacerbates your
insecurities
yes because like when you're hiding
everything you don't want everyone to
know
the idea that they'll find out becomes
more scary
so one thing that gary said to me my
favorite quote is your insecurities are
the jail of your emotions
and basically his recommendation is if
you're insecure about something
put it out publicly say it tell people
like oh my god that's so scary as
honestly
as deliberately as you can tell them
what man's security is
and then when you do that it goes away
because
once you own it you dissolve it
essentially yeah there's no power over
that there's no
and that's my god a lot of people tell
me like you're so honest like you just
i'm like yeah because it's
my it's my way of gaining power over
myself
yeah where i'm no longer scared
someone's gonna find something out or
like right
like because i'm truthful about yeah i
struggle with
not self-conscious about being short
sometimes
so i'll just say it yeah because once i
say it then it's like
okay like it is where it is that's what
you texted me when you were in the lobby
you were like hey i'm here and i'm the
short bald guy
that's exactly right so
for me and that's helped me a lot with
my content right because
you you one thing you like about my
content is my kenzie morgan
oh my god kenzie's great and it's like
growing up i
loved being different characters from
accents i love that
super bummed you didn't bring the wig
but whatever
and it was when i started doing those
characters
on camera and being more of myself when
i loved people started to connect with
me more
right but we're so scared to do it
though that's the problem right
[Music]
they can sense it they sense that
authenticity and i
i i often was asked you know about you
know my following and the fans and what
you know people being interested in me
and i'm like i don't get it like i don't
really know
i said but i guess they just must be
able to sense my authenticity
they just under they they can sense that
i'm being honest i answer a question
when i'm asked it i don't give some
sugar-coated
you know crappy answer that's boring and
thanking every sponsor under the sun and
forgetting to answer the damn question
like
i'm i'm just being honest and i'm just
like
being showing up and you know i was just
talking about this with some friends the
other day about you know
um you know my persona and you know
who i am in front of people and was
there ever difficulty in that and it's
like i kind of just always showed up so
i never had to be scared of it
you know like that's the thing too is if
if you because again if you put out
there
on your social media or however you
present yourself in life
in a way that is inaccurate the fear
only gets bigger about them
finding out so if you just get it out
there right away like yes i'm aggressive
yes i'm emotional yes i fly off the
handlebars
yes i also cry and joy when i finally
won like i mean if you just like
are who you are then you're never
shocking anyone either i think
one of the imposter syndrome is real
right feeling like you shouldn't be
where you are
and on social media i couldn't imagine
putting out
something that's not myself knowing that
maybe i'll
run into somebody and i won't be who i
put out yeah i said
i say that about the filters i'm like
look i mean i might brighten a photo if
i'm backlit or something just so you can
see me
but i don't want to put a bunch of
filters and i don't want to look like a
damn puppy dog on my videos because
i don't want someone to see me and be
like your eyes are a lot smaller than
they were in your instagram story
they're like oh you look so different
it's like oh you're way
you know this than you i mean i saw a
picture and i was like surely this
person is not that tall i know that
person sure enough
i looked up you can add apps you can
have apps that make you taller
and so look if you know there's you're
going to have to face the reality sooner
or later so you might as well just get
on with it and what's crazy and what you
found out is that it's so relatable
like more enjoyable a lot of people
blame
social media for uh people having uh
low self-esteem and all stuff it's no
it's not social media how you use social
media
true if you use it dishonest totally
create a persona that's not you
then of course your self-esteem will
tank because you're creating this
persona
and getting feedback based on life
something that's not
real yeah so the idea of your real self
becomes yeah
this bad thing whereas if you just put
out who you are
yeah all the feedback is for you based
on who you actually are
show up authentically um
so you were a power lifter correct
i was a power lifter and you didn't miss
a single day of training in
four years is that accurate over a
thousand training sessions
okay that's intensely committed i
respect that i love that
i'm the one that doesn't take rest days
so i respect that
um and then you um
then you trained gary you obviously took
a break you have gotten back to training
a little bit so
i have so many questions about like the
actual training
itself that i have even asked myself
like it
it's like pandora's box working out and
food is like what works give me the
answer everybody wants the pill
i'm using pill with air quotes around it
because everybody wants to know like
just do this and it'll work so um
what's the answer just tell me right so
like first and foremost
what do you need to do for weight loss
if your goal is to lose fat
yes calories are most important yeah
number one calories are most important
and and the first question
that comes up from this before someone
is going to be in the comments that
should be like no
it's not true well not all calories are
created equal
the good and bad calories it's like it's
like okay well
to answer that you have to say well what
is a calorie like what is it
right right energy that's it it's a unit
of energy yeah
in the same way a mile it's it measures
the length of something a mile is a mile
whether you're on sand in a forest in
new york miles a mile
it's not like a mile doesn't change like
the
what's within the mile where you are it
might take longer to travel a mile based
on where you are but a mile is a mile
same thing with a calorie a calorie and
broccoli is the same as calorie in a
doughnut because it's just measuring the
energy in the food
that changes the nutrient composition
and nobody in their right mind can argue
that a donut is as nutritious
as a full salad right right right
looking at the total calories the right
energy within that
right then you can get a gauge for how
much energy you're putting in your body
right and what most people who are
struggling to lose weight
don't realize is how much energy they're
putting in their body right
and you could be eating protocol clean
foods totally
but eating too much 100 energy period
100
whether it's eggs whether it's nuts i
mean trail mix my ultimate demise
granola and trail mix my ultimate demise
i'm like i can crush a thousand calories
in a second with that stuff because
i mean like i finally measured a serving
of granola that i was eating
and i was like oh god i'm eating three
servings at a time
which is like you know 500 calories and
i'm like it's my
go to the store and like grab a handful
or go to the
pantry and grab a handful and shove it
in my mouth like that was good i'll have
another one
there's a couple servings right there so
yes 100 calories and it's like
it gets out of control real fast and fat
is the number one way
to jack it up because it also astonishes
me how many people don't know how many
calories are in a gram of fat and
protein and carbohydrate
and fat has nine calories per gram and
carbohydrates and protein only have four
so for every gram of fat it's double the
calories basically so that's why it goes
so fast
generally speaking the two things i like
to focus on are calories number one and
protein number two got it if your
calories are met yep your protein is met
yeah yeah true if your calories are
number one
especially for yeah yeah we're going to
stay on the floor calories number one
protein number two because protein
that's gonna be the most filling
it holds you up the most
okay it's the only one carbs and fats
don't do that protein is the only one
that allows you to build muscle
okay so if your calories are good your
protein is good from there
everything falls into place based on
your total calories exactly
so it's actually like people here like
i just don't think that works i mean
seriously like a year ago i would have
been like
i'm doing the work i swear and i am like
you don't know me but i am an ultra
healthy eater like i don't again i don't
even desire bad food and i'm like i'm
the one that's putting like
11 adaptogens in my like one tablespoon
of chia seeds made with
water hot water like i mean i'm like
yeah so i get it it's
very easy to get it out of control a lot
of people
is a very interesting psychological
phenomenon but people when they're
struggling to lose weight they almost
wear their struggle like a badge of
honor on their sleeve sure
they'll be like i'm doing everything i
sure know it and when you even
possibly adjust that they're not sure
like that there might be
missing something they get super angry
and defensive which is why
like the fact that you were like you
know what i'm going to track my calories
yup to anyone who thinks you're actually
doing everything right check your
calories for three days
dude i agree like a week just like a
couple days or a week you can you eat
mostly the same things
so that's why i did it for like whenever
i was home i would do it and i was like
oh when i'm home
or when i'm on the road now it's so much
easier because i'm like i get it like
the
dude look i can't eat ran don't add fat
in my breakfast and
don't snack on fat and then i'm fine
like i finally learned the techniques
but
so okay so you know the value of protein
in my head i'm like is protein
a real thing like is this just like a
manufactured
propaganda to sell animal meat like
slaughter some cows
because i've got a little bit of an
issue with uh slaughtering these days so
my vegan vegan journey has somewhat
begun
uh or at least more humane journey um so
that makes protein difficult by the way
real as in real um but so okay so tell
me about protein like just give me the
quick
overview of why like it's a real thing
so you really need protein
that's very important it's very very
important now
like anything you could go to either a
stream if you go to the bodybuilding
community
they tend to say you need like 1.5 grams
per pound of body weight which is just
no you don't okay that's massively
excessive okay so
what's the what's the what's the gold
standard for how many how much protein
like if you look at the science 0.7
grams per pound
of lean body mass now
for you because you're already very lean
we can use your body weight
right you're already very you don't have
a lot of extra fat okay so i'd use your
body weight
i would say 100 to 110 grams would be
great for you yeah that'd be fantastic
but if you have a lot more fat to lose
you don't want to go by total body
weight because let's say someone's
250 300 pounds
right okay so like got it
got it got it but i hate saying that
because then people like well how do you
know how much clean body mouth
like look in the mirror dude it's just
it's tough so i try and go with the
immediate metric possible yeah
yeah okay well then what's uh what
so protein grows muscle what maintains
muscle same thing
okay got it carbs can spare it but
protein is the
most efficient at building it's the only
one that built it and the most
how in the hell do kids grow big and
strong on fruit roll-ups then
fortunately i mean kids are growing
anyway they're going to grow up
and like there are things called newbie
games like you could watch someone
go to the gym for the first time their
nutrition is awful their training is off
but they start to grow so it's a little
bit bigger
that diminishes after a certain amount
of time you didn't have to at my age
then
yeah well yeah especially your training
level right like you're
in advanced training like the stuff that
you do now
i bet you couldn't have done it when you
first started at all yeah of course like
when you have a beginner they can make
progress way faster with far less
than someone who's super advanced so
what is the value of carbohydrate then
energy is super important hormonal
response is super important
okay um generally speaking i love carbs
and i found yeah to do way better when
they have enough carbs now
cheeto is a big fat right now i know
we're gonna get there we're gonna get
there don't you
my issue is with things that are
unsustainable
and a lot of people look at keto as well
i lost 20 pounds in 30 days so i'm going
to do keto it's like okay but can you
so you're saying it could be like a
cycle you could do a cycle of keto if
you wanted to lose some weight you know
everything is worth trying yeah but in
today's society it's just like
how realistic is it to not eat carbs or
like right
the amount of carbs that they allot so
what's about the amount of carbs that
you should have
if you are like a you know if you um
train a little bit so basically
literally or not at all yeah i mean for
me i say
i want to make it as simple as possible
so if they get your calories in check
yep that's number one how do you know
how many calories you should eat so
basically there's a lot of different
ways you can do it um
take your body weight i like goal body
weight goal body is a little bit better
because
if you have a lot to lose then you're
not basing it off
yeah okay full body weight and people
are going to be like well how do i know
what my goal
is
stop overthinking it stop making excuses
body weight yep again just yeah [ __ ]
number yeah
stick with that consistently for 30 days
guarantee you make progress
yeah and then from there you want to try
doing keto cool so carbohydrates is one
per pound too
one gram per pound carbs carbs for gold
okay
carbs like don't break my heart
these carbs could have anywhere between
like 20 percent of your diet so like
60 it's like it ranges and that's i hate
the
percentages just because it changes
based on your body sure
sure sure 20 for someone who's 110
pounds is very different than 20
for someone who's 210 pounds right
because calories are going to change
so by the way i've always taken a new
account total body like
i'm like oh you're a boy i'm a girl you
should probably have a little more than
me
or yeah and that's generally just
because men tend to be bigger
right yeah so it's like but if you take
two people man woman who are the same
exact size
they're probably going to have about the
same calorie rates
i have found women tend to respond
better to a higher carb diet like women
tend to be more carb
sensitive they do better with it mm-hmm
a lot of times for whatever reason
there's whole thing that fruit is going
to make you fat lately i love those
i love those videos those pictures of
like looking at the banana and saying
like
luther with your with your face looking
like what you know this is the face i
want you to think of when someone tells
you that a banana is going to make you
fat
are you kidding me no fruit i'm like
when did you ever [ __ ] meet someone
who got back from eating watermelon
right
yeah i i i totally agree like i think
he's overweight
too many blueberries
and that's why when you break it down so
gently like calories protein they don't
believe you totally
it can't be that simple totally
supplements do you take like yeah but i
heard about keto about intermittent
fasting
you know why calories protein that's it
right in that space they make a whole
bunch of excuses why they haven't done
the easiest thing
yep figure how many calories you need
get enough protein figure the rest out
it just can't be let's just put the wig
on and let's just tell them all about it
um okay fat then what's the roll of fat
hang on you're a coffee lover take a
drink you need to energize
there you go because careful is there
too much is there too much cream in
there is it going to make you fat
that's really important especially from
the hormone perspective yeah
now i feel like a girl would hear that
and go okay and a guy would hear that
and go i got hormones
well actually it's important for both
okay yeah
and we all have all of them we all have
all of them you just have a little more
testosterone and i have a little bit
more estrogen
that's very important to know we all
have all yes different ratios yes
the now there's another thing as well a
lot of people hear that
that has nine grams per calorie in that
college program
and so they avoid it completely but if
you look at
what's also important remember is
satiety how filling is certain
carbs fill us up more short term that
tends to be more filling in the long
term
so if you want to sort of be strategic
with your food having
carbs at the at the near the end of your
meal where it's more fast at the
beginning because you put fats at the
beginning
then by the time you get to the end oh
even in the timing of the meal it
matters
so fun but staying full sure that's a
that's a weight loss tool
you know like keeping your calories in
check tools and let's say you have like
some avocado and then some rice
and grilled chicken you might want to
start with the avocado and the chicken
mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah love it okay
um uh so i feel like and this will kind
of play into the guys
and also me like i mean there's times
where i want to gain more muscle
so what do you have to do to gain muscle
what i want to say is it's super
important for everyone like women
yeah is that what happens is that what
happens as time goes on with most people
as they've kind of
like lost that sort of um
i don't even i don't know if it's age or
like the hormones that uh
reduce your muscle mass but essentially
you just kind of you're like oh it's
just getting old getting fat
and is it because of our reduction in
lean muscle mass well
a reduction in muscle mass is like
absolutely massively detrimental and
scary
and it's really interesting a lot of
people say oh getting older means that
you lose muscle mass that's not
necessarily the case right
what's happening is as you get older
people tend to move less
right right they tend to do less
physical activity so then
of course not bailing hay anymore
exactly you know
we're not picking girls up come on swoop
us up
so i mean it's basically you want to
build muscle and people hear that a lot
of women especially they hear like
build muscle and they think arnold
schwarzenegger i know it's like
the way that i frame it is not lifting
heavy weights
for fear of looking like arnold forzager
is like not riding a bicycle
[Laughter]
right it's like you're not gonna ride a
bike in all of a sudden
you're like i'm sure so many bad ones
yeah i know you're right you're so right
it's like
lifting heavy weights doesn't make you
bulky in possession for a year
right if you want to get bigger muscles
a lot
[Laughter]
blades of glory that's all i can think
about the iron cross um
getting stronger two different thousands
okay
okay well what makes you strong and what
makes you bulky so
and this is the people that will say
more reps and
less weight or more weight and fewer
reps generally speaking
fewer fewer reps and a heavier weight is
how you get stronger
okay bigger generally if you're doing
higher repetitions and lower weight
that's where you end up getting bigger
which is counterintuitive to other
people yeah if you're looking heavier
you're going to get bigger not the case
if you want to lift heavier weight for
fewer reps between like
five reps to 10 reps is a good range for
strength
once you get into the higher repetition
rate with lower rate
like eight to 15 repetitions that's more
muscle building bigger
there's a lot of variables within that
mm-hmm
that's the hypertrophy sort of zone
right yep
and but remember if you're not eating
too many calories
you won't get bigger okay so that's key
so if you're
if you're in a caloric deficit
maintenance floor deficit you're on your
spot and you're tr and you're
and you're lifting weights to gain
muscle you won't you won't get there
will you get stronger
okay you can get stronger but you cannot
gain muscle because strength isn't
solely a function of
muscle size right it's really important
to remember strength it's not solely a
function of how big your muscles are
go to the gymnastics go to the figure
skating right strength is also a
function of how good your brain is
telling your muscles to fire how quickly
do your muscles fire
how many motor neurons can it recruit
rate cutting that's why like you can see
someone jump super high but they might
not be really big you know how strong
they have
to jump really high these sprinters have
how strong they go really fast
it's not just how big the muscle is also
how efficient your brain is
so it's about recruiting more of the
muscle
at the same time over and over and over
again
wow how do you do that
that is 59.99
yes just essentially the stronger you
get yeah
the more force that you can produce and
the more force you can produce
the faster you can accelerate force
equals mass times acceleration
the greater force whoa this isn't a math
program back it down
thank you there you go that's better for
me i went through a program
i used have you ever heard of rp
renaissance periodization
um okay is that another okay um and like
look
i look i was one of those people i did
like i was i had nick was helping me he
was like emailing me and
um you know at one point i was like it
doesn't work
because i was eating too many [ __ ]
calories like i was totally wrong
um but they have like they kind of like
that sort of gave me a little bit more
of a scientific insight into
they do what's like massing and then
cutting so
you know eating in a calorie surplus
usually more carbohydrate while you're
lifting weights like the will train for
carbs thing
and gaining muscle and then going on a
cut afterwards to like reduce the body
fat but let the new
lean muscle mass emerge that you've
grown so is it important to go through a
cycle or can you always just stay in an
absolutely spot-on lean
beautiful state because i wish you'd
tell me the second one
i i wish the second one was possible
but this is not how anything works in
life got it
it's like if you want to get bigger you
need to be in a calorie surplus
gotta want to lose fat you need a
calorie deficit so doing both at the
same time
well it's possible it takes massive
patience and an immense amount of time
yeah the gains are small more progress
by going through phases
yeah yeah how do you do it
for me because you recently you were you
were very again you'd call out whatever
you've got going on you you put it on
the table that way nobody can
you know come to you and be like wow you
got really skinny why are you like no i
wrote about it didn't you see
um but you know you were you were a
bodybuilder and then you you know you
did your lifting and then you went on
the road and you know things got you
know you just
you weren't putting you you weren't
putting yourself first and that's fine
i believe that that's there's we all go
through phases in our life where those
kinds of things happen
so you got back on the train and you're
like okay i want to get my [ __ ] together
and um
it's time to it's time to get back to
where i'm comfortable again essentially
right so
what did you do i did four times
after that i was like super burned out
but then i started coaching gary
when you're going from hong kong to l.a
to
new york to miami everywhere so like it
was insane yeah so i focused way more on
my business
so i let my own personal fitness go down
where i got back on track
now mainly i'm in a really cool phase
where
i get newbie games because i took such a
time period away
mm-hmm that now i get back and my games
are gonna come back way more
fun basically i'm training four days a
week like super simple
um and i'm not trying to be like a world
record powerlifter at this point i'm not
trying to like lift as much weight as i
can in the world i'm just trying to get
back in make it a habit yeah
yeah i think this is a whole separate
topic too many people rely on motivation
rather than habits and when you rely on
motivation
you're going to burn out at some point
like for you right now working on the
cabin you do it every day
yeah it's like that's just what you mean
like i think about when i set my alarm
clock the first thing i think about is
working out like that i got to work out
at this time so i can get done by this
time
and it doesn't mean that sometimes you
don't have to motivate yourself to do it
but
because it's not an option for you it's
just part of your daily routine yeah
you need less motivation because you
built that habit that's my goal with
everybody
is to get to a point where your fitness
yeah um yeah i feel like this is one of
those things like
figuring out what's right for you um you
know for me i've gone through phases of
working out i
did everything from running to then
doing like
you know uh some like some weightlifting
wait
finally when i started lifting a little
bit of weight i realized oh wow you
don't get bulky i was totally one of
those thinkers um
then you go through like you know high
reps lower weight
and then i went through um some yoga and
you know you go through these phases and
you're like i don't know what's right
and then i did crossfit and i was like
man
this is it for me but i i mean from i've
tried a lot of things
and you know i still don't i guess i
still don't even know is that what's
perfect for me
um it does that even exist about what
works best for my body and what's most
effective or is it just
i feel like you're just going to tell me
danica like be realistic it's about
consistency it's about exertion of
energy it's about burning calories and
it's about your total caloric intake i
mean
that's the thing it's not the sex people
yep
like you're experienced yeah this is
right this is wrong right stupidness is
smart
that's not how it works for me it's
number one what are you gonna do that
you enjoy
that allows you to see consistent
progress without taking over your whole
life
yeah that's it yeah what do you enjoy
yeah
but i think people really run into a rut
when they think okay well but
what's the best what's the best one i
need just the one and then they hate
doing it
they don't even like it and then they're
not consistent with it they're like well
i did that and i didn't see any progress
well how would you do it for oh like
four days
it's like that's a problem for four days
if you found something you love you did
it consistently maybe it's not perfect
maybe it's not the best for you but at
least you did it consistently and that's
how you see progress
yeah how long do you feel like you need
to give something
a fair shot 90 days 90 days
that's a high five right there jeez um
it's okay um no no high five
like i fought for that in my book i was
like you know they
i'd have to fight hard it's my book
right but there was you know a whole
like oh they want to hear like you can
be
[ __ ] miracles in 30 days i'm like
water weight i can make you have a
miracle for water weight
in like a week yeah so much water weight
in a week you'll hate it
i know right and it'll be gone and
you'll be fat again you know
um but it's i said look i don't feel
like you can
truly make things happen
unless you give it 90 days like because
you have that honeymoon phase when you
start
because you've probably changed your
diet you've started sweating
you're getting rid of more water weight
then your shock in the system some
newbie gains
um you i love that new term and uh that
i didn't know it's not
it's new to me um and and and so you get
in that first sort of
three weeks ish you know you kind of get
this like oh my god everything's so
amazing and i've lost like six pounds
and
then they get into like weeks six and
seven and eight
and they're like this sucks nothing's
happening anymore i've actually gained a
pound
and i'm like just hang in there and then
finally by the end of the 12 weeks it's
like
i felt like maybe you can tell me what
the reality is of this but i felt like
you know you get that newbie gain you
get that
like water weight loss is a lot of it i
feel like and then you start building
some muscle up and muscle weighs two and
a half times more than fat
these are getting the muscle on i felt
like you know until that body catches up
with
burning that fat off like then i feel
like at the end of the 12 weeks the fat
has now come off based on the muscle
gain
based on you know the total caloric
expenditure as well
what the hell's happening that makes me
think that i sort of just like i
literally just wrote about this from the
perspective of
there's so much confusing information
because someone will try and die
they'll go on their diet and they'll be
like three days in like this is the best
diet ever
yeah and they're
three days like they're telling all
their friends it's amazing and they get
like two weeks in and all the time like
their weight spikes up and they're like
but they don't want to tell anyone about
it
they're like they just keep it quiet but
then they try something else in a month
like oh no now i'm doing this and this
is the best
so you always have people saying this is
the best this is the best this is the
best you're like
well i don't know like cheryl said this
and karen said this and i don't know who
the [ __ ] to believe
and so number one is i like that 90 day
timeline because when you actually do it
for 90 days no [ __ ]
like through the times that are tough
through the times when your weight goes
up through the times when things
aren't going your way then you actually
see if it works or not right
so that's number one it's funny i've
been approached by people to write a
book and they're like
what kind of book like 21 days i know
right they wanted like 30 or 60 i'm like
i'm gonna write a book called the five
year plan and it's going to sell zero
because exactly what's the five-year
plan exactly that's what you need
and i always say it's like listen if i
told you that in five years you would
look the way you want feel the way you
want for the rest of your life
would you do it it's like yeah
absolutely
but you're gonna keep choosing the seven
day detox cleanse the 31 day the 20 day
fix the 14 and a half hours
whatever the nine seconds to freedom you
got it
whereas if you just [ __ ] took the
five year plan you did it you'd be great
yep
but what happens is especially with
weight loss
the scale fluctuates yes for no [ __ ]
reason
for far outside of fat gain and loss
weigh yourself at the beginning of the
day than the end and you'll just be like
what
seriously i don't do it that's why then
drink a bottle of water you've gained a
pound
yeah like that's how it works so people
and even though they might logically
know the scale is not going to go down
every day
subconsciously they get really upset
when it might spike up they
they get really [ __ ] one of my most
popular youtube videos was explaining
the science of scale fluctuation
understanding why sometimes it go down
sometimes it goes up and i've seen
pat i have three main patterns i've
identified people
where it'll go like this down up and
then you're going to see a spike and
no matter what and a lot of it's due to
a menstrual cycle sometimes you're women
that's what it is sodium whatever it is
yeah but it's totally
that game totally people will get to
that two week three four week point
like ah [ __ ] this this is too bad it's
not working it's like
solely based on the scale but it's like
well you've lost measurements with your
clothes you're down in size
your strength is up you're making
progress like people have been telling
you you clearly look leaner but you're
gonna get pissed off at the scale one up
half a pound like what the [ __ ] are you
doing
yeah it's and that's why that 90 days is
so important
because even and especially when your
scale spikes up even especially when you
feel like it's not working
that's when you have to keep going
because that's the only way you find out
if it works patience
patience like if you want something
you've never had you're going to have to
do something you've never done
exactly right i mean people just aren't
willing to do it i think the hard part
is like
with so much stuff being thrown at you
it's like no keto diet no intermittent
fasting you know this and people
like as soon as they get to a point
where it's tough they look for the other
answer
it's like no when you get to that point
where it's tough that's when you keep
going
that's when you have to stick with it
and maybe that way isn't right for you
but at least you found that out at least
you stuck through it you saw it through
like you know what yeah i don't like
this
it's like cool i had even thought to
myself for a hot second
you put information you put a video out
about it
i was like it's i'm i'm 37 it's my
hormones
people get so mad totally i said that to
myself i'm like i'm gonna go to my like
my doctor and like you know that i get
my like monthly
yearly checkups and i'm like i should
probably get my blood tested for
hormones i think that's why i'm gaining
weight like
like i i mean well i like stopped racing
and i gained a couple pounds and i
didn't actually what's the funny is that
i didn't nothing really
i don't think anything fit too much
different like it wasn't dramatic enough
for me to notice because then again
we're talking about 112 to 103 when you
had to do that in high school
big difference so you know gaining a
couple pounds at a 110 is like
know especially with girls our pants are
already painted on
you know there's no room for the paint
to crack you know
um yeah but a smaller frame like you
feel it way more
oh you absolutely do and it's uh
it was one of those things where i was
like i just have to face the music
and so what what do you what do you
struggle with
like what are your what do you feel like
um you know for yourself
what do you what are you what are the
most difficult things when it comes to
let's say training
when it comes to training um
i'll be honest i'm at a point where i
mean i love training i enjoy it
it's great i think for me
personally the hardest thing that i go
through so i grew up powerlifting i grew
up
lifting as heavy as possible that was my
main goal my main goal was to get the
four times my body weight like less than
10 people have done that in the history
of ever
so like that was what i wanted to do
always just i thought my 255 deadlift
was good
nothing that's double your body it's
amazing so wait what
you could double absolutely
so go ahead what i wanted i want to do
that forever
so for me the hardest part mentally is
not
going max effort every set right as like
someone who comes from the competition
max ever being like one rep max
like getting to a one rep max basically
i do crossfit this is all my vocab this
is my vocab baby
so yeah i get it because then you go
into the gym you think like oh
especially if you're training by
yourself because you probably don't have
a trainer
as you are a trainer and i go into the
gym too and i just do my own thing and
then i'll be hanging out and kind of
doing some back squatting i'll be like
but you know just like put a little more
on and do one less rep and then just put
a little more onto one less rep and then
all of a sudden you're like let's just
check the piano
let's just check it let's just see why
not and so for me
from my background that's always been my
hardest is because i'm super competitive
i just want to see
how i get better am i getting better and
it's almost it's a huge fallacy because
i know the only way to get better is not
slowly through lifting more weight there
are many ways to improve
that's where i struggle um and with
nutrition i struggle because
i just really like eating pizza
i just love pizza so i'm at a point
where it's like i'm not trying to step
on stage i'm not
i'm not going to get on myself
so do you just take it into caloric
consideration and just go like look i
just can't eat a lot of other things
today but
listen i could have more rice with this
chicken
or i could not have the rice at all and
then have pizza later
and that's way better now let's do that
what do you think about um
i feel like it's always such a topic
people just they love it right because
they get freedom which is to me
it's i call it an unhealthy association
with food it's it's an
unhealthy relationship with food when
you live for your cheat days or your
cheat meals
it is a dangerous road to go down
because to me you're just saying that
you hate healthy food because you're
like i love the unhealthy
so much so what you know like what are
your what are your thoughts about
cheetos i [ __ ] hate the term sheep
right i hate it maybe it's just got a
wrong title because it's called
it's it's complying that you're doing
something bad right and when you
imply that you're doing something bad
then it's sort of like hey don't pull
the fire alarm it's like oh
i'll start with the pull apart because
like the more you create this
this idea that you're cheating you're
doing something better the more you're
like oh i can't wait and they spend all
week planning yeah
yeah it's like then they binge like in
no situation is binging good
okay it's not saying you can't have
these foods in moderation but the fact
that you're
you're spending an entire day shoving as
much of it in your mouth as you can
it's not a really good habit but you
shouldn't be doing that
so for me number one is like if you want
to have a treat have a treat you want to
have a food out of food but don't say
you're cheating
what happens is a lot of people will
then develop these binge cycles
with that type of eating and they create
this idea of good food bad food
and when you do that then you create
this really bad relationship with food
or as
soon as you have one treat it's like i
did something bad i must have screwed up
it's like listen
no one got fat from having one donut no
one got fat from having one slice of
pizza no one got skinny from having one
salad
no one got jacked from going to one
workout right it's all about what you're
doing consistently over time
so for me i would way rather if someone
wants to slice a pizza or wants a donut
like
learn how to have it in moderation
rather than only having it on
binging or completely eliminating it all
at once like there
it's a generally healthier lifestyle to
learn how to balance it
rather than to well if i'm going to eat
it i'm only going to eat it along with
10 000 other calories of junk
it's like why don't you have it as part
of an overall healthy diet yeah they
kind of do a dive on it and use it as a
catalyst to just go crazy it's terrible
i am i don't you know when people ask me
you know what to your
cheat foods or whatever i'm like i don't
really have any i'm like i crave healthy
food i'm like but if there was something
i had
i'm like maybe too much of something
healthy i'm like or you know like
granola and trail mix i can go a little
nuts with
i'm like i i i go walnuts with it
and uh literally yeah i'm figuring
that's yeah that's clever
um i don't even mean to i just uh and
then uh yeah
then and then there's wine i love wine
okay
look it has a lot of calories i
understand um
and then um and then i would say the
other thing would be chocolate like
those are my things like and i like dark
chocolate so dark chocolate some red
wine little granola and trail mix i mean
that's
like where i've arrived at finally that
i that for
me are like my cheat my i don't even
like calm cheats they're just like i eat
a little too much of something good
and you enjoy it and yeah you get back
on track yeah
and like for me the way i always frame
it to make it as simple as possible is
don't eat like an [ __ ] like that's it
everyone knows
what to eat yeah and like if you're
spending most of your day eating like an
[ __ ]
that's your pub you're an [ __ ] a very
small minority of your week is fed
eating like an [ __ ] you're probably
gonna be
fine but just generally yeah you don't
eat like an [ __ ] yeah
yeah feel like an [ __ ] a little bit i
just believe cheat days happen
they happen naturally that's kind of
like right like life happens you went on
you know whatever right you know like a
party or something you go to a baseball
game and you're drinking beers and
whatever like all the cheat happens
or you're in an airport and there's just
not a lot of good options so you just go
these are my so i don't ever
put i just they naturally happen or
you'll go out to a really nice dinner
and you're like you know it's a
like for me i'm a little foofy with my
food like tasting menus are my cheat
meals when i go out like i'm like you
know what
but i actually they're very open i do
ask for dairy and gluten free on my
whenever i go somewhere and they
actually accommodate it very kindly
but yeah i mean i'll kind of bring
whatever they i'm not like worried like
oh my god i've had too many ounces of
um but that's what i think about that
now the other thing that's kind of in
that
similar vein but much more positive
actually is the rest days
and i'm terrible at them like i have to
force myself to rest and i still
give myself the latitude to call a rest
day a five mile walk in an hour and a
half of yoga okay
let me ask you this and this is like
super like transparent and honest do you
let's say for example you don't you you
can't work out one day
whatever do you get anxiety uh
only if i could so like let's say
when i traveled to new york on monday i
had to get up
at five o'clock in the morning get ready
get on the plane
come you know i didn't work out at all
that day no big deal i had to get up so
early
no stress on that because i believe that
just like cheat meals
let's just give them their stupid title
um i believe that rest days happen
naturally
perfect i go on vacation and i can not
work out for the whole week
it doesn't mean i don't want to be
active like it doesn't mean like i want
to just sit there and be a
lard right like i'll be like hey let's
go for a walk hey let's go to
you know let's go walk let's go skiing
let's go uh
on the boat let's go swimming let's go
like i like being active
but i don't have to work out that's the
important distinction to make and and i
just spoke about this it's really
important
if taking a rest day
gives you anxiety or makes you resent
your family or your friends because
yeah you should be able to take a rest
day without it destroying your
yeah or getting pissed at your kids yeah
yeah
if taking resting is something that you
can do and it's
okay like that's good yeah
i also think that when you make it part
of your day-to-day like sort of gary
does
then that's great because it's just a
daily habit yeah and
i mean i walk every day i like to walk i
try to walk at least 30 if not
if not an hour like 30 years yeah just
because like
i feel better for it yeah i try to get
my workout in early in the morning six
o'clock seven o'clock yeah
it's done i feel better for it yeah if i
don't get a workout in
it's not the end of the world but like
i'll always try and be active because i
feel better for it
but i think the issue arises when you
literally get a panic response from
like going on vacation it's like oh my
god am i gonna lose all my progress it's
like
you didn't make all your progress in a
week you're not going to lose it right
there has to be that balance and that's
what really people struggle with
it's usually either not working out at
all or
going to the nth degree and really going
crazy with it you have to find the
middle ground
yeah amen all right i want to power
through
um some topics
and i just kind of want to hear your
perspective you can talk about them as
little as you want as
much as you want um but but i i i'm
curious about a lot of these things so
okay um pre-workout for supplements
just pre-workout so my favorite
pre-workout is coffee amen
super affordable yeah tastes great yep
i mean the research on caffeine is
outrageous performance enhancer
neurologically i've been told by any
train any any trainer any fitness expert
somebody that i'm talking to about like
what can i take
um whether it was nick or whether from
rp or whether it was you know other
trainers i've talked to
and they always include caffeine yeah i
mean
the only sport that caffeine is not good
for
is the biathlon when they're shooting
and they try and shoot in between hearts
because it's a narrow window a narrow
window
any other sport improvement beta
blockers
perfect caffeine terrible
so from a performance perspective energy
perspective is great now
i personally don't buy pre-workout
because it's way more expensive
and it's just like i like coffee enough
to work yeah that's perfect for me i
look at all the [ __ ] in it though
there's so much there's artificial
sugars there's
a bunch of stuff i can't understand so
i'm not
as concerned about that stuff mainly
because number one it's dose dependent
like you're not having that much of it
it's not like
you're gonna be that's not the majority
of your diet okay and for me it's like
okay
i always have to think about both sides
of the coin here so if someone isn't
going to work out
if they don't take it or if they will if
they do take it am i
more happy that they're actually being
active even if they're taking some
artificial sweeteners and all that stuff
with it it's like better off
that they work out than not at all right
for me right like the the benefits of
physical activity
are far outweigh than any potential
negative side effects of the other stuff
so i would way rather than do that if
it's the choice between the two if that
makes sense
so the five calories of your
of your and do you believe that that all
the
that the calories are accurate as in
like i feel like i've heard that
um you know like let's say with like a
diet coke or something like that where
they say that your body reacts to
artificial sugars if it was real
that is arguably the dumbest [ __ ]
thing i hear on a consistent basis well
thanks a lot
you just offended me i actually tweeted
about this recently it's just like
well so no there's technically no
calories but
your body thinks there's calories so
your body switches them
and then all of a sudden you get fat no
there's zero calories or zero calories
it doesn't trick your body
like people cite the most outrageous
articles saying like well no because uh
sugar sweet okay so then you eat this
thing that's sweet and all of a sudden
uh your body thinks that there's
calories it's like what
are you out of your mind there's
literally zero research saying that
now some people hear this and go in the
comments be like oh my god he's saying
you should drink like
all the diet coke he's like no you
shouldn't have 12 cans of diet coke a
day it's [ __ ] stupid
but why i mean generally speaking you
probably just wouldn't want to have that
much
what a day is okay but like no worries
got it moderation
exactly moderation but no two like zero
calorie things
are zero calories that being said there
are some tricky things you can do so for
example
it's spray butter straight butter stuff
you know yeah so
what they'll do is they'll say zero
calories right but if you look at the
serving size they'll be like
5 000 servings in it and the thing is as
long as it's less than five calories per
serving they can say zero
so if like you do let's say one serving
is the highest phrase
i mean i use that spray stuff no this
was a reach for this was this was like a
handout for oh my god you're helping me
thank you because you wear it
i mean like for me i use um because i i
feel like it's better coverage and i
don't use like spray butter like i can't
believe it's not butter
um but i use the you know 100 pure
um avocado oil or 100 just
you know coconut or 100 ghee or
something like that
oh yeah they do kind of say or whatever
yeah but a diet coke is one serving per
can
yeah it might be three or four calories
who knows
but zero calories it doesn't convert to
sugar in your body
by some magical potion got it
pre-workout the [ __ ] out of it then if
yeah that's your thing
a lot of pre-workout has beta alanine in
it i used to take beta-alanine all the
time
i had a trainer told me to take bait
ally man i took beta alanine for
probably
you get tingly from it no i never did no
i took it for
uh i don't know eight or ten years
i actually stopped and thought [ __ ]
what's going on
and i didn't put it together and i was
like maybe it's the lack of beta-alanine
so beta-alanine
there are several there are a very small
handful of supplements that actually
work
creatine beta-alanine caffeine
are like the major ones more will you
plea what's a good supplement company
for that like where would i get
i was going to ask you for after but
anybody would want to know where do i
get beta alanine
i mean i would literally just go to your
supplement store it doesn't matter
because you get pre-workouts and they
put just enough to do nothing
[Music]
which means they can put whatever the
[ __ ] they want and whatever amount they
don't actually have to tell you
so it's like natural natural ingredients
are natural anything that's this
proprietary blend is just don't get it
just get pure beta-alanine if you want
it beta-alanine is good for higher
repetition longer duration
creatine is better for maximal strength
force production so if you want to let
heavier weight creatine is a really good
option
if you just want to make you puffy it
can it can make you retain water
so creatine monohydrate can do that
which is my preferred
option for it but if it upsets your
stomach or makes you hold on to water
micronized creatine is a really good
option no
micronize what yeah exactly and while
you're writing
creatine keep in mind supplements are
supplemental
right it's great because you already
have your training in check you have
your nutrition in check yeah you have
your sleeping check yeah for people
listening who are like oh
i gotta get this but yet you haven't
trained three times a week
for like in the last three years like
you got a problem focus on your actual
habits
got it okay the supplements don't work
unless you work
if that makes sense amen good stuff
okay keto keto okay
uh we kind of covered it we can skip
over this one it's up to you
it's not for the long term listen i'll
say this
if you can do it long term great but
most people
they're super defensive about it they're
like i love
i lost 40 pounds in the last 10 minutes
i'm like
that's amazing tell me how it goes
through the next year it's like
if you can do it forever fantastic
personally i like going to a party and
having potato chips without feeling like
i'm a failure
but that's just me my friend did it and
she was like i got the app and
everybody's losing tons of weight and
she's like i did and i became obsessed
with food and she's like i'd screw up
one little thing and then just be like
well [ __ ] it i'm not in ketosis so
whatever you know people are very quick
to
make they they're they like to reduce
health to nutrition that's all
like well it's just nutrition and then
all they think about is nutrition like
there's a lot more to health
is what you're putting in your mouth not
to mention it's the relationship you
have with what you're putting in your
mouth
if you're looking at the room around you
what everyone else is eating you're like
i wish i was having that i wish i was
having that
if you're looking or judging everybody
basically they're eating oh they're
stupid they're gonna die early they're
gonna get cancer it's like you need to
chill
you need to relax have a donut and chill
for a second
because this there's way more to life
than having such a
reductionist view of everything you're
doing with dude it's like let's just
chill
yeah right yeah like let's just enjoy
ourselves stay on track don't eat like
an [ __ ]
but relax it's okay
i hear you i totally agree okay weight
training
i love it i mean i see no reason for
anybody not to weight train
and there's a million different ways to
wait training there's like
power lifting there's bodybuilding
there's just full body weight training
there's body parts splits there's a
million different ways
i'd suggest you try everything and give
everything a shot for 90 days at least
see how it goes this is a miracle think
about it if you tried every program for
90 days
then you may be dead you'd just be super
fit you'll tried everything for fit
and fine i mean for crossfit if you love
crossfit you crossfit
yeah crossfit what's your thoughts on
crossfit so
i i'll give you the pros and cons the
pros
i don't want to hear the cons so just
tell me no i'm just kidding
tell me them all for the pros across it
i love that they
use full body compound movements i love
that yeah
you're competing against each other yet
you're cheering for each other it's
amazing what the hell
like for me if you're getting people up
off their couch and into a gym yeah
like that's way better than anything
else yeah my issues with crossfit
it is very it's too easy the barrier to
entry to become a coach in general is
too small
to become a personal trainer you can go
online and take a course and all of a
sudden you're a coach
to become a crossfit coach it's too easy
to like and especially for the olympic
lifts
i have some friends that are coaches
they're amazing they're incredible
i also know some crossfit coaches who
spent a weekend
i have my level one i got my level one
certification
and um it was a weekend right yeah it
was two days
and um look the test was not challenge
it was was challenging the test was
like you know holy crap what's the right
answer but um and you have to pass that
but as far as the hands-on training goes
um it would it's it's a it's a
dangerous position to be put in right um
is the single most dangerous and complex
movement
and i suck at it um so yes i
and so there there wasn't enough time
spent on all of the lifts
you know you did like a med ball clean
um but like let's face it we don't ever
really do med ball cleans in class
so you know i mean i get like the
mechanics on some level but
yeah the the the i mean i i see what
you're saying
to be an assistant coach you could you
should you could have your level one
but you need to go through the olympic
lifts my biggest thing is like
i my foremost concern is number one
getting people to work out that's number
one yep
after that we can keep them safe yeah
and
jumping brand new beginners into doing
yeah dangerous
super duper 100 okay bar class bar class
i've never done it so i have to be
forthright with that from the people who
have done it and told me they told me
it's
very difficult which for me like
difficult doesn't equal effective but
if you enjoy it like great um i have
no nothing to add because i'm ignorant
on it
okay that's fair that's super fair but
like once you get kenzie out how would
kenzie like bar class
she does it all the time she's done it
like two times the best thing ever
changed her life
her butt is so tight now
i mean look i've taken a couple bar
classes and i judge it heavily
because we could literally be doing bar
right now it's like activation on small
little muscles like look at me i'm doing
my left butt cheek right now
do it right it's like it's like tiny
little movements where you're like you
know you like lift your leg and you
isolate this one
muscle underneath your butt you know and
then there's like one little part where
you're using
two pound weights with and look it burns
so i don't understand because i'm
really strong but they'll be like
constant movement
of it of the weights and you're like it
burns well yeah you're holding something
up in the air for a couple of minutes
of course it burns kind of burns and
you're not doing anything you're not
holding anything so
it's it's a little like i mean yes you
kind of you know there's some sweating a
little bit and you know you're kind of
like whoa
that burns but like i don't know
anything where you don't
you can almost not tell that i'm doing a
movement
to me it's not really i didn't know that
like i want to encourage
movement for sure yeah something that it
sounds like to me
is that people are chasing a feeling
instead of a result they're chasing the
feeling of it being difficult
of it burning people chase the feeling
of sweating you listen to people talk
about their coaches
i had the best coach he just kicked my
ass like why is that your best coach
like how's the results fit
yeah like people like to feel like they
got really just like
kick to the ground like just like
they're sweating and panting it's like
there's a difference between chasing a
feeling and a stimulus versus
chasing a result most people will do
something but they don't actually get
the result they want
it's like we need to stop chasing the
feeling of burning stop feeling the
chasing of
chasing the feeling of sweating and okay
let's do this for 12 weeks and then
measure your actual results
how much fat i've lost how much muscle
have you gained how much strength have
you gained when you start doing that so
are you telling me i need to try bar
class for 90 days
i no because you hate it
okay moving on um i mean this is
something i used to do
um endurance training you know like
running like think about
there are a lot of people that go and
they jump on that damn elliptical and
that's the other thing there are two
things that i judge heavily
bar class and the elliptical machine and
i've done both
so i'm qualified to at least have some
kind of an opinion but the but the
elliptical
to me is just a cop out you know i use
the elliptical exclusively to cut weight
when i was wrestling because it was just
so easy on my joints
you just move you're just like going now
i listen
again something is always better than
nothing
always yes i agree look when i see
people and i'm like
again i want to judge for a second and
then i'm like but they're here
my thing is then it's like my issue
isn't with the person on the elliptical
it's
the person i see on the elliptical every
day seven days a week
for three years and they aren't happy
with their results
right right if you want something you've
never had you're gonna have to do
something you've never done
people who do the same exact workout
over and over again for years straight
like if you want to change how you look
you got to change your workout if you
want to change how strong you want to
change your performance you have to do
something different yeah
the elliptical if you want to warm up on
the elliptical brakes yeah yeah
yeah yeah but if that's your workout
yeah you need to handle something else i
also
um my my other sort of part of it that i
think is when i see it is i'm like i bet
they just don't know what else to do
that's exactly right they're they're
scared of the weights they don't know
how to move them they don't know what to
do with them
you know of course they go to the weight
section like no that's where all the
gold's gym burly men go
you know they're like they don't they're
not comfortable there so i think a lot
of it is just the
uh pure comfort level of stepping off of
that elliptical
or off of the treadmill or off of that
bike and getting over somewhere else and
like pulling down a machine
and pulling on a bar or lifting
something up that's absolutely
i think and the most important message i
give to anyone in that situation is
no one gives a [ __ ] what you're doing in
the gym yeah like a lot of people are
scared to go to the weight section
because they're like oh my god
like people what are people going to
think yeah no one's looking yeah yeah
nobody gives a [ __ ]
it's like no everyone's too focused on
themselves yeah you see someone do five
crunches and let their shirt up and then
like they pretend to wipe the sweat off
but they're actually looking at their
stomach
yeah that's pretty good everyone's too
focused on themselves than they are to
focus on you
and it's almost like everybody in the
gym is
in their own mind thinking everyone else
is looking at them yeah it's like it's
not no no like
get the [ __ ] in the gym yeah some squats
yeah some push-ups yeah
like just get better just do something
just get in there
lift some weight so i have i mean my
like my general
sort of theory on on again because of
like again i'm not a
i didn't go to school for any of this
but it's just uh you know 20 some years
of practice
um so 20 25 years uh thanks but
um is that cardio can change the size of
your body
okay but it won't change the shape of
your body
so weights are going to change the shape
of your body and so if you look at
someone two people that weigh the same
amount but
one has you know one has muscle
definition
they're going to look leaner i like to
use the example you're
a marathon runner versus a sprinter
you look at google a marathon runner
like they'll be very skinny
yeah but
in a very short period and to do that
you have to be super strong yeah
it doesn't make sense for american
runner to carry that much mass yeah
because it's gonna yeah
yep but that's the perfect example of
someone who does
cardio no weight lifting yeah someone
who does cardio yeah with my program
there's there's
uh seven workouts a week and i encourage
there to be two two a days and two rest
days um
and so the uh the cardios
are not like go run for 30 minutes
they're all interval
right because my theory is like have you
ever seen a sprinter
without a six-pack that's right pole
volatiles
sprinter everything like that's exactly
right so super low body fat
high muscle densities yeah outrageously
strong yeah
um uh protein powder i love it
yeah it's great it's it's a super
convenient way to help you get your
protein intake
especially if like it's 8 pm and you
don't want to have a chicken breast or
whatever it's just like
take a quick shake it's fantastic um a
lot of people so you mean the body's not
sensing that sweetness and being like oh
it's sugar
okay good i'm gonna totally double down
my dosage because again i don't eat as
much meat as i used to so
i pretty much only eat fish so you know
i'm not having fish for breakfast unless
i'm of course in japan so
um so uh and then it's pickled um but
it's um it's something that i now have
in my diet again i since i started
tracking my calories i eat i mean i've
many i eat protein powder every morning
and i have lost some weight
yeah actually i don't even know i
haven't even weighed myself but look
shit's fit
fitting a little looser so i know it's
working um but i eat protein powder
every day so
um it's i just i'm just double checking
is that okay it's
fantastic i think again just like with
the supplements is trying to get
as pure of just protein as you can yep
there's no need to get the protein with
the supplements with this
that just get protein yeah okay that's
it okay
um what about the paleo diet um
i i like it from the perspective of any
diet that gets you to focus on
more whole unprocessed foods lean meats
proteins veggies fantastic i love it
i have issues with it for a number of
reasons number one they say well this is
how paleo manning
it's like well which paleo man because
there's paleo people from alaska there's
other people from
like a rich paleo person because the
research on that says like there's a lot
of different paleo diets so that's sort
of
nitpicking on that also people who take
it to
an extreme and dogmatic and like no no
like
i'm like i also like as a joke sort of
piss them off like i guarantee you if
paleo man was here he'd go mcdonald's
yeah but so overall it's fantastic i
think
that's a very great way to exemplify not
eating like an [ __ ] okay
right i would call it don't eat like an
[ __ ] yeah yeah that and that's it
but like to say that that is 100
optimal for health it's like no there
has to be some moderation too
and like there's no research showing
that
having some processed food in an overall
healthy diet is bad for you
and i think when people take it to the
degree of like oh my god you had
you had one doughnut like all of a
sudden you're going to do it's like no
it's not
like that it's like if that's the
majority of your diet amazing
i start writing obituaries when i see
somebody pick up a diet a doughnut
people get
super cultish with their nutrition fats
i've had people say like
it's like i hope you get cancer and die
i'm like oh my god like
just because i don't agree with your
nutritionals evil
i'm not that mean but i will judge you
but i will judge you yeah uh
intermittent fasting
uh so i actually have a huge video on
this that i made
it's i'm totally fine with it it's 100
fine
i have some issues with it in terms of
that sound contradictory
um i'm finding that from the perspective
of it works as long as you're in a
calorie deficit
for fat loss okay so a lot of people
will say does intermittent fasting have
a fat loss it's like not if you're in a
calorie surplus
like if you're not in a calorie deficit
it will help you lose fat
now if intermittent fasting helps you
from the perspective of you're not
hungry in the beginning of the day and
you like to eat bigger meals at night
yeah great that's fantastic yeah i also
think there are some health benefits
outside of weight loss that
you can glean from intermittent fasting
whether it's mental focus
autophagy like there are some cellular
benefits you can glean from it as well
that being said some people
it triggers them to binge whereas like
if they put off eating their calories in
the day
and they binge eat at night in which
case if you struggle from binge eating
there's no reason for you to do it yeah
just perpetuating the problem
if binge eating is an issue do not ever
make it fast because it will absolutely
exacerbate it yeah but if it works with
your schedule
yeah if you're not hungry for breakfast
great do it but i am not humanly capable
of it
at all one million percent i could skip
dinner before breakfast
like but i still don't want to
intermittent fast
hell no nobody wants to see me
nobody wants to see me in uh uh without
food for more than
four to five hours i expect my
girlfriend gets super hangry you can't
she doesn't eat every two or three hours
she just gets rid of because i don't
need big enough meals
i do i like my meals are 3 400 calories
and like i am
[ __ ] starving in three or four hours
like
holy crap i get it yeah
[Laughter]
i mean i've tried everything so i've
tried it i have my opinion too but
tell me oh god where do i begin
i can go out does it work for anything
it works for losing water weight
yes which doesn't [ __ ] matter i know
people are saying you could do that
anyway just don't drink water for a day
you lose water
you'll just peel the rest out just don't
eat salty foods you lose water weight
like go in a hot tub you lose water
water weight means nothing okay people
are so right
how do i just get rid of the water it's
like
why don't you want to get rid of that
because like not the water
yeah when people ask about losing weight
like oh my god i have something to do in
like three days or like five days or in
a week i'm like
well all you can do is lose water weight
yeah that's all you have is an
opportunity
like that's all you can do in a few days
that's it but that and it does work
it will come back but it doesn't even
make that big of a difference unless you
lose an
outrageous amount of water it doesn't
make that big of a difference on your
physique either
totally yeah it's just a number it's
literally it's just like yeah i lost
like four pounds
it's like great okay you look the same
is there any
is so is there what is the downside i
know i'm stupid they're absolutely
ridiculous
and guaranteed like oh my god that is
outrageous they worked for me okay
define worked i lost
like eight pounds okay then what then i
gained a bath
when i started eating like a human
no one can do that forever except maybe
a few people who
that's what they sell the people who
sell juice
yeah people who that's how they make
their income yeah that's people get
really pissed off me
when i say juice cleanses are [ __ ]
stupid and then the person who just
raids my comments actually this is
ridiculous and i go to their page and
they [ __ ] sell
juice of course i'm like okay what about
anyone who just doesn't sell it
like what do you guys think and almost
everybody's like yes i lost weight but
then i started eating normally again i
gained it all back and
i don't know it just doesn't seem
sustainable it's like people get really
mad
when they have something to lose from it
and that's the people who are
gaining financially from selling people
in this fake idea that
juice them and they're a [ __ ] idea
they're really really expensive
they're super expensive and it's all
marketing and you're leaving behind the
good [ __ ]
just the fiber 72 hour plan yeah
literally they're taking
all of the good at it yeah all you pull
from it is sugar you're only pulling
water and sugar
let's keep the fiber let's just get rid
of the fiber and the protein we don't
need any of that
get rid of everything that makes you
full from it and we're only going to
feed you the sugar water
and you know just stick with that you'll
be fine good so juice cleanses
scratch that so then how do you feel
about celery juice
[Laughter]
i did it for a while too how long did
you do it for ah
a few weeks did you like it
it makes you go to the bathroom more
often okay
it might just be from chugging a bunch
of liquid though
who knows maybe chugging a bunch of
others actually
increases your like how you're offering
your bowel movement
whatever it's like it's fine if you're
if you're really
blocked up and great take it people
tout it as actually the major guy who
sells
something yeah he blocked me on
instagram anthony
oh no he's a the medical media medical
meeting he blocked me on instagram
really
um which is super interesting i told
gary about it
yeah i was like this guy blocked me and
he was like
that's how you know that they have
something to hide because if
you don't have anything to hide there's
no reason to block you right it's like
if you're telling the truth
then you'll talk to anybody about it and
for me is i have nothing wrong with
seller juice
as a drink like but when you're selling
that as
it actually infuriates me i'm about to
get pissed because you know what
he talks about how it cures cancer he
talks about how it's like
there's literally there was a story
someone who died
they didn't take their cancer medication
they didn't do their protocol because
they followed this guy's advice because
they're like oh i'll just have celery
abuse they're
they're touting this as an end-all
be-all for
psoriasis for curing cancer for your
illness if forget weight loss let's just
talk about like
people's lives right you're telling it
as a cure
right so it's not a replacement
but if you want to add it in be my guest
right if you want to drink celery juice
and if you look at his website look at
his about page
i have zero medical experience i am not
medically certified
it's because he's supposed to i mean the
medical medium is essentially says he's
getting this information intuitively
right yes he says he's getting it from
spirits
right he's like but i'm not actually a
doctor but i'm going to make my name
in spirits i'm just like what the [ __ ]
like seriously like and i'm sure i would
like to sit down with him and talk with
him and i'm
gonna be a great but it's
outrageously misleading it's like
i couldn't imagine telling people i
couldn't imagine making my name
medical something and having no medical
experience like that in and of itself
should be a
warning sign it's like his medical on
his name but then you go deep into the
like the about page where no one's gonna
read be like oh by the way a disclaimer
i'm not actually medically experienced
it's like oh you're just getting this
from spirits fantastic
trusted source let's um
let's put that fire out and uh let's uh
let's kind of like close out with you
know what um
what's what do you what do you hope what
do you hope to do with your
career with your information if you were
to project out into the future
um what's next so where does it go
i've been really fortunate um
i love what i do like for me i'm not
trying to
i think the thing that allows me to be
so honest with what i do is i don't have
anything to sell
like i'm not trying to sell any
supplements i'm not trying to sell any
programs ps
tough spot to be in probably at this
point because you're getting more
popular
and as you get more followers i don't
doubt you get approached
i get approached all the time yeah but
i'm lucky because
i i haven't i'm not going to sell
anything like
i've literally made my entire career
based off of honesty honesty
and i couldn't imagine all of a sudden
being like oh hey guys now i have all
this supplement that i want you to take
it's like
what so i'm glad i didn't ask you about
that i have that written down too
supplements yeah
scratch that okay i love speaking
i'm trying to do a lot more speaking
engagements which i have a bunch of
books for this summer
2019 but eventually i'll write a book
and i would like to write the book the
five year plan
like love it i'd love to do that because
it's truthful
marketing wise people are like you're an
idiot because nobody's going to buy the
five year plan
but like it should be also titled don't
be an [ __ ]
the five year plan i like that you know
what maybe that'll be the title book and
then you get to write the forward
but for me it's like i just want to put
as much free content out to help as many
people as possible
and that's it and it sounds like hippy
dippy and whatever is the truth it's
like i have nothing to sell i just want
to put out free content and that's it
like that's what i love doing
yeah what else makes you happy outside
of helping people
dead lifting i really like deadlifts you
just want that one
let's get back to the pr world uh harry
potter
huge harry potter really harry potter oh
um
is hobbiton harry potter no inhabitants
that's lord of the rings i went there
yeah we went there in new zealand okay
that's different then
it was pretty cool okay harry potter so
how does that
um what have you done to nurture that
love well i recently just went to the
show
on broadway which was oh fantastic but i
mean if you read any of my content on
instagram or even on youtube like
i sprinkle in harry potter references
all the time so like
for me i wouldn't get it yeah you
haven't read any of the books
no movies no oh god you're like
so we can't like i don't agree with like
medical medium is number one and you're
like then people like me
never read the books it's shocking to me
i don't like to read
respect and uh the movies are
really long there's how many are there
eight yeah that's that's time consuming
that's right you know when when game of
thrones had their final season i hadn't
watched about five seasons i watched the
first couple i'm like you know i'm just
going to pick it back up
and sure enough it was almost like a
soap opera you're like oh my gosh
they're still doing that same thing
same thing yeah i never watched that
stuff yeah yeah yeah
so then you are one of those people then
i'm like oh you don't watch game of
thrones you didn't watch the final
season
i don't think we can be friends yeah
well thank you so much
you're very inspirational very direct i
i really hope that you never lose that
um you know lose that side of you and
um you know not letting people get to
you because it can be hard
like being in the public public forum
and you know the more popular you get
you you know i've seen it with other
people who
you know generate more and more and more
awareness and
they can you know get to a spot where
their content becomes
a little um
you know they're trying to uh appeal and
appease everyone
and you aren't going to you can and the
more you try to the less you'll actually
do do you have some but one more thing
um
you know with obviously going to hang on
would you go to college for again
had a better title than actually
behavioral health psychology
and training garyvee and being around
him
and his mindset for so many years
um you know are there like a few
are there a few things like maybe three
things that we can think about
as as human beings to exist in the world
and live our best life yeah i would say
number one is let's say we're talking
about social media
um if a lot of people are scared to put
out content on social media
because they're worried about the hate
they're worried about the comments
you're scared of putting real
content exactly right like being their
real selves right about who might be
hating on it who might be in the comment
section
and one of the best lessons i've taken
from gary is
instead of getting angry at the person
leaving the able comment you have to
feel bad for them yeah because
imagine what a sad person that must be
to be spending their time on someone
else's page leaving
it like when was the last time you ever
went on someone else's page another
negative comment exactly because you're
having a stranger
exactly so for me anytime you're worried
about putting out content for fear of
someone else
if you remember if and when they do that
you should feel bad for them 100 percent
in a really bad place yep another one
another garyism
doing the right thing is always the
right thing it's one of my favorite
quotes from him
in terms of like instinctively in your
gut you know
what the right thing to do is you have
to ask someone like what do you think
about this it's like you know the answer
like doing the right thing is always the
right thing uh
and then for the last one on top of my
head i would say
if you're unhappy you can change it the
choice between optimism and pessimism
is within you 100 it doesn't mean that
it's an
easy choice but it does mean that you
can consciously choose the optimistic
route
as long as you actively deliberately
consciously choose it
yeah well said jordan thank you very
much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
you